ce sont de faire la tête à nos voisins
c'est ainsi que l'on pourrait résumer
l'opération organisée hier dans 25
villes françaises pour améliorer la
convivialité dans les immeubles des
fêtes de quartier ont rassemblé les
familles qui d'habitude ne font que se
croiser exemple au plessis-robinson
région parisienne avec laeticia legembre
et christian galley pour la famille
charrier le plaisir de se retrouver
entre voisins est une idée qui fait
recette depuis sept ans qu'ils vivent
dans cette cité jardin il rêvait de
réunir tout voisinage
l'occasion était trop belle depuis
plusieurs semaines tout le quartier est
en ébullition
l'idéal est tout de suite avec mon autre
voisine qui dans un ovale au des eaux
cette
on s'est appelé on avis alors on fait
quelque chose audiard fait quelque chose
ses voisins florence les connais bien
dans son immeuble tous se sont mobilisés
même les papys mamies du dernier étage
qui au départ ne voulait pas venir
changer d'avis bien le mot d'ordre la
convivialité une ambiance bon enfant
tout le monde est invité à condition de
ne pas arriver les mains vides à sortir
de sa solitude partager ses expériences
et découvrir de nouvelles têtes
une façon de voir autrement ce qu'on
connaît déjà des gens ils se connaissent
pratiquement tous les enfants se
connaissent on se retrouve tous à la
sortie de l'école n'oubliez rien non
plus d'exceptionnel et c'est un petit
plus
même les enfants n'ont pas été oubliés
un mardi soir pour pouvoir se coucher
tard les intéressés qui ont sauté sur
l'occasion savent apprécier
moi je m'amuse et on peut faire la fête
tard brassage des cultures des
générations d opinion à l'heure des
nouvelles technologies comme une petite
récréation dans des emplois du temps
trop souvent sur change sur internet
connaît pareille que voient les voisins
vont devoir penser un petit peu les
problèmes quand même puis un succès
total dans toute la france des dizaines
de milliers de voisins ou partagé hier
le verre de l'amitié au plessis le
quartier a déjà décidé de renouveler
l'expérience
ici tout le monde est d'accord le
bonheur c'est tout comme l'art de bien